next question if you had to live as one
of your characters for the rest of your
life who would you choose I probably use
the character of Seth Rogen from this is
the end cuz it's kind of me ah oh no no
guys this is a family website oh hi dear
help me here hold this in your mouth yes
thank you
great Oh doh you ripped enough the first
question is oh no his cake ha free him
did go bubby was the funniest encounter
you've had with a fan I've had a few
I've had a lot of people yell at me
because I won't admit I'm Zach
Galifianakis I had a guy in Shake Shack
come up to me the other day and say whoa
are you Seth Rogen and I said yeah he
said no you're not and I said yeah I am
and he said how tall are you
it said around 6 feet anyway ok you are
step protip hi guys hi oh hi of all your
movies which one are you most proud of
I'm really proud of sausage 4 already
honestly I've been working on it for
like 10 years and I think it's very
unique and funny next question
I even have faith in you yet how high
were you when you wrote sausage party
varying degrees of highness did anyone
sound to the movie and then later back
out after realizing the movie's full
story like that never happened
but what did happen is Puff Daddy was
pretty into being in the movie at one
point and then found out it was an
animated movie and not a live-action
movie where we all are dressed like food
and that made him lose interest very
fast would you rather have a pizza slice
for feet or cupcakes for hands you can
eat them and they'll grow back pizza
feet can we cool hi can we expect a
remake of the Kim and Kanye video but
with you as Kanye no we can't I'm a Kim
man if you could play any Disney
character and a lot of live action
adaptation who would you choose Ursula
from The Little Mermaid
of that woman great character strong
female character as well and so as a man
I would like to take that what are some
tips you would give someone to laugh
like Seth Rogen I don't know just lead a
very unhealthy lifestyle